the PGA of America is one of the world's
largest working sports organizations
with golf in the US and 84 billion
dollar industry the group is made up of
29,000 PGA professionals who teach play
and compete at golf courses across the
country it started a new chapter last
night with a new leader at the helm Suzy
Whaley was sworn in as the first female
president in the organization's 102 year
history we spoke to Whaley at the
Country Club at Mirasol in Florida about
fighting for her place in the
male-dominated sport and how she plans
to change it for the better
what's your first golf memory I was on a
driving range at a golf course when my
parents played golf in my swimsuit
hitting golf balls with the boys from
the pool as a young girl growing up in
Syracuse New York
Suzy Whaley craved sunshine skiing and
outdoor sports but she found her true
passion on the driving range some of the
boys I swam with were like come on we're
gonna go hit some golf balls you want to
come and I said yeah absolutely sure
enough my mom got called off the course
because I was in the wrong attire and
thankfully I had this amazing mom who
instead of yelling at me for being in
the wrong clothes said do you like this
that I said I actually loved it the
title 9 arrow was just beginning so
Whaley competed on a boy's high school
golf team since there wasn't one for the
girls still gender wasn't an issue until
Whaley tried entering a tournament and
found it was only for boys what did you
think then you know I didn't think was
fair and I remember thinking well I
don't understand I just want to play
golf I want to have fun playing golf
just like they do but we didn't dwell on
that in my house and my parents ended up
moving clubs where I was allowed to play
right so there was just always this
support that if you want to do it go do
it the best you can and that's really
the way my sister and I both grew up we
weren't afraid to fail with that support
behind her Whaley played collegiate golf
she then passed on law school to go to
PGA Tour school she competed in some
LPGA Tour events where she met her
husband bill also a PGA professional and
they started a family
that's when Whaley realized she wanted
more opportunities to play I watched my
husband play in these tournaments
literally weekly and it was aggravating
I wanted to play against him and I
wanted to win and that just a little
competitive Susie bill encouraged her to
join the PGA of America the idea that we
always say behind every strong man
there's a strong woman it seems like
behind every strong woman there was also
a strong man that you need that support
we have a great my husband I have a
great relationship and he has never not
supported me or a decision I've made or
help me get up when I've fallen check
out the third shot here at the par-5
18th in 2002 while working as a head
golf pro in Connecticut Whaley became
the first woman to qualify for a PGA
Tour event in 58 years and just the
third ever we celebrated and about two
minutes after I had signed my scorecard
finishing the event I had a phone call
and it was from the PGA Tour asking me
if I was going to accept the exemption I
said can I have some time to think about
it and there was this lengthy pause on
the phone and he said well okay why did
you want to think about it yeah I hadn't
even considered it I have anything I
really honestly had never imagined that
they would allow a woman to play on the
PGA Tour the wind kicked off a media
storm with Whalley fielding about 3,500
interviews three months later she still
hadn't decided on playing it was a woman
and how would people see that I was
representing club professionals my peers
across the country and that's a huge
responsibility if I'm gonna tee it up
I'm gonna T that for real it was her
then nine year old daughter Jen who made
the decision we were reading a story at
night as we always did and it was about
taking opportunities and taking chances
and being brave and when we finished the
story she said well the mom why aren't
you playing and I said well you know I
am and I walked down the stairs and that
was the night I told my husband I was in
it was that it was a seafood yeah what a
moment for this young lady no she
play the weekend but it's certainly a
week Suzy Whaley will never forget since
then three other female golfers have
competed in a PGA Tour event and Whaley
has spent her career promoting inclusion
in the sport but leading that effort as
one of the sport's top instructors
wasn't enough so in 2014 she decided to
run for Secretary of the PGA of America
a path that automatically leads to the
presidency she faced a delegation of 111
men and only three women did you face
backlash because you're a woman you know
I had a I had it was difficult and
challenging and I'm sure but nobody ever
would speak out against it right nobody
else is gonna say they're not gonna say
that's usually how it is nobody says it
to your face so I mean you can sit there
and you can kind of wallow in the what
ifs I just wasn't willing to go there I
wanted to share what I could accomplish
I wanted to share why I was doing it I
want to get more clubs in people's hands
I want to make sure the game looks more
like the communities we serve
Suzie Whaley is the newly elected
Secretary of the PGA of America Whaley
got the votes needed becoming the first
woman elected a national officer of the
PGA of America
my daughter grabbed my hand she was mom
you won
I go no we have to she's like no read it
again and I looked up and I it was like
in almost it takes your breath away
because it's humbling and it's exciting
and it's an enormous responsibility and
it's when I was ready for a month before
the election the PGA of America fired
its president for using sexist language
on social media four years later it is
Whaley taking over that role one of our
biggest challenges I think which I look
at is an enormous opportunity is getting
more people on our golf courses we want
to welcome women to golf courses we want
more junior girls and junior boys
playing golf how do you make golf more
diverse we try it every avenue to make
sure that people know they're welcome
that golf is affordable in certain
places around the country where we can
help you find that right so can you wear
sneakers absolutely
do you have to have a golf outfit no you
do not do you have to have equipment no
most facilities across the country have
equipment for you um you can just walk
right into the door and do it I want you
to realize that this is for YouTube
inclusivity in a sport known for its
exclusivity and while that's something
Whaley learned firsthand for her golf
was never about breaking down barriers
it was and is about the love of the game
do you ever look back and think what if
you'd stayed in the pool instead of
going to the driving range that day in
the bathing suit you do think about
things like that in your life when you
think about the turns you take I'm
blessed and and I have this amazing
association that has given me
opportunities that are tremendous and
and giving back to that is something
that I cherish it just given me so much
I'm just incredibly grateful and she
continues to give back she still teaches
whenever she can and I have to say you
spend five minutes with her you just
want to play golf the sport is lucky to
have her I just I just love that her
daughter her nine-year-old daughter was
the wind beneath her wings and her
husband yeah mr. caddy she has two girls
and you can thought everything is about
showing them an example of home and it
shows you the importance of parental
support that story really without a
doubt